my name is Joey Acharya I'm the platform
technical lead at a small start-up
called ricotta and I'm gonna be talking
about streaming ETL so first some
background so as I said I'm Joey I work
at ricotta was where kana do we build
machine data management software that
means that we collect logs server
metrics from an company's entire
infrastructure so the big thing there is
we're all about scalability so our
customers are typically pulling in 10
terabytes of logs per day or more I used
to work at Cloudera that won't be a
surprise our infrastructure is all built
on top of Hadoop and before that I was
at the National Security Agency my
general background is distributed
systems security data processing Big
Data all the fun buzzwords and I wrote a
book if you're interested in OOP
security why but seriously you can go
get this from O'Reilly so some history
of these kinds of data problems a legacy
data architecture and I put legacy in
quotes because this is legacy in the big
data world is you've got data producers
that are using systems like flume or
scoop to send their data over to Hadoop
which is like a giant distributed file
system they write the data there and
then you've got these processing engines
that are doing batch computations or
queries over it so you have to first
write the data to the file system and
then you can sort of query it in batches
this is great except that you want to do
things in real time everybody wants to
do things in real time because it's real
time so this is what a more modern
stream data based architecture may look
like you still have data producers
they're gonna produce to a pub sub
system like Kafka or Twitter recently
put distributed log into the Apache
Incubator it's a very similar system and
then
got these stream processing systems that
are reading the data out of Kafka or
subscribe to the data of Kafka as the
data is produce so you no longer have
latency that's measured in hours or days
for doing your processing but you can
actually get it down to minutes or
seconds or sub seconds in addition to
the stream processing systems you may
just have Kafka consumers which are sort
of standalone processes that are reading
from Kafka and setting it to some
downstream data store typically you
still have HDFS in the mix that's
probably going to be your store of
record it's a great long-term store and
then ideally you want those stream
processing systems actually power your
real time visualization you don't want
the data to have to hit your Hadoop file
system before you can start sending
results to your customers so I'm gonna
zoom in a little bit to these three
pieces here storm flink and spark
streaming and this is going to be a
super super high level primer I'm not
gonna go that much into theory or that
much into detail on these systems so I
definitely recommend you read more or go
to other meetups where they'll go into a
lot more detail about how these systems
all work stream processing in general
what I mean by stream processing
I mean events are flowing in or objects
or records are flowing in and you want
to do something to them
I sort of abstract stream processing
down to these stages there's probably
more or less depending on what you're
actually doing but by filter I mean
taking data and throwing away things
that you don't care about extraction is
taking sort of raw records or raw data
and pulling out structured information
from it so people always talk about log
data is being unstructured that's
actually not true log data is highly
structured it's just that usually when
it's given to you it's given to you as a
bunch of bytes or as a file and you have
to parse it in order to understand the
structure projection is basically taking
a record and throwing away the fields or
parts of the record that you don't care
about or basically taking data and one
schema on a def
to another if you've done sequel based
processing this is basically any time
you do a select and you're only
selecting a subset of the columns you're
doing a projection aggregation is
counting things or adding things up or
sometimes more advanced if you're doing
percentiles but basically it's math join
is when you've got two different data
streams and you want to bring them
together and then modeling is all of
that really advanced stuff that everyone
really wants to do which is where you
turn your raw data into this magic box
that will then predict the future for
you so I'm going to zoom in a little bit
on filter extract and project and for
the rest of this talk I'm going to
summarize those as a group to what I
call data transformation so going back
to those sort of three stream processing
systems the storm is like the granddaddy
of them it's been around the longest
it's described as a distributed
real-time computation system which
doesn't really mean very much but the
way that storm is packaged every
application or job is built together
into something called the topology
topologies operate over tuples
that's what storm calls records or
events and the way that you get data
into storm is with what they call a
spout a spout is a source of a stream it
can be another screen processing system
it can be Kafka it can be a socket that
you have open where you're just neck
getting data to it and then bolts are
sort of the arbitrary logic in between
and bolts can do any of those stream
processing functions they can do
filtering and they can do aggregation
they can do joins they can do arbitrary
functions so the idea here though is
that storms are relatively low-level
model you have to do all of the work you
have to assemble the bolts you have to
write all the bolts you have to hook up
your spouts in order to get data and
it's not very turnkey from that
perspective
Apache sparks a little bit
it's also probably the project that has
the most hype around it these days it
does both stream processing and batch
processing you'll sometimes hear the
stream processing part of spark called
spark streaming the way that spark
breaks down its data is it takes a
continuous stream of records and
discrete eise's it into what they call
is a d-- stream and add a stream is a
sequence of rdd's rdd's or what SPARC
uses for basically any table or
collection of records and the real
difference between SPARC streaming and
other streaming systems is that it's
inherently what's known as a micro batch
which means that before any of your
functions are called inside of your
SPARC streaming job the data is going to
be batched up into small windows or
small chunks of data and then you
operate over those the advantage is that
you get very high throughput at some
sacrifice of latency as you need to wait
for some data to come in before you can
start processing it apache flink is
actually very similar to SPARC it's also
both a batch and a stream processing
system it's a little bit newer than
spark spark was started want to say in
2008 at Berkeley but I may have that
year wrong flink I think first came out
in around 2011 they have a similar
abstractions they called their stream of
data a data stream which is an unbounded
collection of records
unlike spark streaming Flinx streaming
support is not micro batch it is record
at a time which is also the way that
storm works and when you're building up
your flink streaming applications you
can explicitly do record at a time
processing or you can specify that you
want to do it over windows that's very
useful if you're doing any kind of
real-time processing on event data that
has timestamps and you want to like
calculate an aggregate rolling window
for the last five minutes or something
like that
I also mentioned Kafka before but
haven't really explained it
it's a pub/sub messaging system
implemented as a distributed log it's
very popular as a source and a sink for
stream processing applications it's very
high speed
it has great scalability great
durability and very easy to understand
Garen delivery guarantees for the most
part it does at least once delivery
which means that it can send you
duplicate data under certain failure
scenarios but it won't lose data so long
as the system is configured correctly
you also may have heard of something
called Kafka streams which is a
relatively new addition to Kafka it's
actually a separate librarian system for
doing stream processing it's actually
kind of a competitor to storm and flink
and SPARC but it's much newer I haven't
played with it but any of these stream
processing systems you should feel free
to make use of or play around with
alright so that sort of lays the
groundwork on stream processing so let's
go back to data transformation so I
explained this before but I'll just
reiterate the first phase of data
transformations filtering that's where
I'm taking these multi colored blocks
and only returning blue blocks
extraction is taking what I view as
unstructured data applying parsing rules
to it and then creating a structured
view of the data on the other side and
then projection is basically adapting
the data from one schema to another so
in this case I'm taking out some of the
fields that are in the attributes some
of the fields that are part of sort of
the the top level and then I'm creating
a new record with a new schema where
everything is sort of flattened so
what's the problem with using these
existing systems for doing this kind of
data transformation
well first you think about who's
interested in doing data transformation
yes its software developers they need to
do it it may be data engineers that are
not full-time software developer
but do a lot of software development as
part of their sort of data science
engineering work it could be a sysadmin
that just wants to lightly process the
logs as they're coming in they're not
really someone that's going to develop a
full bore java application this is
someone that really understands how to
configure things understands how to do
scripting lives a lot in the terminal or
maybe an analyst that's very high level
that just wants to modify the data
before it goes into their analysis
process so the tools that you have
available when you're using any of these
stream processing systems are usually
full programming languages you've got
Scala Python Java are the most popular
these tools are great but not everybody
is a programmer not everybody is a
developer a lot of people want to do
these types of ETL or transformation
tasks without having to dip down into a
programming language to do it this is a
great quote from Josh wills if you don't
know Josh wills is he's I believe the
director of data science at slack and
this is stolen from a video presentation
he gave at Midwest i/o and 2014 talking
about feature engineering anyone that's
ever worked on a data science project
knows that the dirty secret is that like
only 5% of it is the fun math part where
you're doing really advanced analysis
using the latest techniques the other
95% of it is all ETL it's all figuring
out how you turn that raw data into the
features that makes the math work so
what's the solution so what we've built
is something that we call work on a
transform it's a library it's
implemented in Java that means you can
embed it in Nha vm language it relies on
another library that we wrote called
Makana configuration reconning
configuration is basically what you want
out of any arbitrary configuration
language which is you start with JSON
you add the ability to view comments
because
writing configuration files without
comments is silly
you actually have specific numeric types
not every number is just a number you
actually have doubles and floats and
things like that and then you remove all
of the excessive quoting that you need
to do in JSON so it's a lot less verbose
and a lot easier to type so I'm going to
talk briefly about the data model this
is not required by the transformation
engine that we've written but it is the
data model that we use internally and it
will help a lot of these other examples
make sense every event has a global
unique ID the ID is actually built as a
hash of the other attributes and fields
in the event every event has a timestamp
that's very important for us you can
only really understand log data if it's
if you know when it happened every event
has an event type ID that allows us to
apply schema information over this sort
of common schema after the fact so
everything coming through our system
uses this single schema but you'll see
the very last field there is our
attributes which is just a map of keys
to values the event type ID allows us to
interpret the body or to interpret those
attributes in a specific way
location is basically where the event
was generated from it can be a data
center ID it could be a rack location it
could be a hierarchy of data center or
rack or data center row rack whatever
makes sense for your specific
environment host is the host name or IP
address where the data originated from
service as the service or process name
that generated the data and then body is
the only really really required besides
timestamp part of an event and that is
just the raw event contents so we tend
not to explicitly interpret body unless
we're doing one of these explicit
transformation steps on it where we're
doing like data extraction and trying to
pull information out and put it into the
structured part of the event which are
the attribute key value pair
so here's an example of something that
you may get from syslog if you haven't
worked with syslog before it's basically
the one of the oldest work based logging
protocols that's out there and so we're
taking that raw body we're extracting
some syslog information from it
in particular the severity and facility
is actually embedded in that 36 that's
in the angle brackets at the beginning
of the body and a couple of other
details that are getting pulled out but
this is just what one of our events look
like hopefully this makes sense there
any questions just not me
so I'm going to show a couple of
examples of how we actually use our
transformation engine to do some
processing on this kind of log data the
first one example will do some filtering
it's going to throw away some of the
logs and only keep ones that we care
about it's going to extract some
additional metadata from those logs and
then it's going to flatten the event
from that structure that has the
embedded attribute map to a schema that
has all of the fields as top-level
fields so specifically we're going to be
filtering out events that don't have
type ID 100 that's the type ID used for
syslog messages we're going to filter
out events where the host name doesn't
start with the letter Z X we're going to
extract a numeric prefix from the syslog
message so it's not the beginning of the
body but that's actually the message
that's the sort of payload part of the
syslog and we're going to flatten the
syslog attributes and the extracted
field into a new Avro schema this is
what the overall computation looks like
first we load the event so this will
make a little bit more sense when I talk
about the sort of architecture of the
transformation engine and how the
library is built but basically I need to
know right now is that the event is
loaded into a single variable
into the context that all of these
actions is reading from and what load
event does is basically take all of
those individual fields and turn them
into top-level variables so they're
easier to access later on filter is how
we filter in this particular case we're
looking for the event type ID and
comparing it to the constant 100 reg X
is how we extract the hostname prefix
I'll go into more details of how that
gets configured in a second we do a
second filter this host prefixed match
that group that one is actually
referencing data that the reg X action
produced so basically any one of these
actions can modify data and a global
variable context and then any subsequent
action can then access that data so
we're going to filter things that start
with a X we're going to do a second
regular expression match this time to
grab that numeric prefix then we're
going to build the Avro record using the
new schema and then finally we're going
to save the output so that the program
where this where this is embedded can
take that new Avro record and then do
whatever other processing or storage it
wants to do with it
so specifically going into the the first
host name prefix extraction it's pretty
simple you give a regular expression
pattern in this case we're looking for
any two characters at the beginning of
the the string we're matching those
characters and then the rest of the
string we don't care about the value
that we're matching against is going to
be the syslog host name attribute and
then the destination is host prefix and
it's called destination but it's
actually a prefix for variables that
will get automatically created by this
action so all of the matches get turned
into match that group with that number
based on the parentheses that you have
in there
match group zero is the entire string
there's also a boolean on whether or not
the match whether or not it matched at
all that you can also access so for the
hostname prefix or sorry the numeric
prefix it's the same kind of thing after
we've filtered by the hostname matching
the letters E and X we're gonna apply
another reg X pattern this time we're
just looking for an arbitrary number of
numbers at the beginning of the string
that's going to be that's going to go
against the syslog message attribute and
this time our destination prefix is
going to be just MSG the other thing
that this is showing is that for regular
expression matches the previous example
of the regular expression didn't match
which basically would only happen if
your string was of your host name was
less than two characters then the data
processing will just stop it'll just
kick out it acts like another filter in
this case we don't want to stop
processing if it doesn't match we want
to continue no matter what but we want
to do different things so if we do match
the regular expression we want to set
the value of the extracted field to the
part of the regular expression that
matched then we don't match the
irregular expression we just want to set
it to an empty string so this gives you
some ability to control the flow of the
data through the system and sort of
decide when you want to stop processing
an event this one looks complicated but
it's relatively simple this is all just
taking the data that we have in the
context and mapping it to the fields of
our avarice schema so this is a way of
building up a new Avro record with a
different schema our customers have used
this especially before Impala supported
nested data types the reason was that
they wanted to be able to store the
average data in a park a or Avro based
data set and do sequel queries over it
and very low latency sequel queries so
they would often flatten some of the law
data in order to further processes it
that's not as required but sometimes you
do want to build sort of purpose-built
tables in your system where you may have
a different schema than the raw event
schema that we're sending data over the
wire with so the next example is
extracting metrics from logs this is
actually very very very important for
our use cases a lot of log data contains
numbers in it and those numbers actually
mean something and if all you do is
extract the logs and write them to a
search engine then those numbers aren't
very useful to you so the specific
example is going to work with HTTP
status logs we're going to extract the
request latency basically the amount of
time that this HTTP request took as well
as counts of HTTP status codes so for
every HTTP return code that's in the
system I want to know how many were 200
how many were 400 how many over 403 what
have you and very quickly there are two
different types of metrics that we can
extract in our system one is a gauge you
can think of a gauge as your speedometer
on your car which is something where you
read the current value that tells you
what the value is right now but if you
read it a little bit later
it'll just be updated to the entire new
value so to understand what's happening
with that value over time you just need
to sort of look at the gauge at various
points in time a counter is a little bit
different a counter is something that
you want to accumulate it's not telling
you what the total count is now it's
telling you the count since the last
time you looked at it
so in particular if you want to count
something like HTTP status codes for
every event that comes in you extract
the status code out of it and you want
to count that status code with the
number one and then our system has
something that will aggregate those
those counts for further query and
analysis later this is an example of the
output of this process which is a metric
event we represent metrics in the same
events
FEMA that the rest of our system uses
basically we've got a custom event type
ID which is 107 for it and then the
attributes are metric name and the
values are a string version of the
floating-point value of that metric and
then the pipe and a letter to represent
the type of metric via a gauge or a
counter metric if you've ever worked
with stats d this is virtually identical
to what their protocol is just jammed
into avro objects so the way that we do
that is we load the event just as before
we're going to use this build metric
action the first thing we're going to do
is build a gauge the gauge metric is
easily built by just taking the value in
the latency attribute converting it to a
double and then setting it to the HTTP
request that latency metric name and
then storing that in the latency metric
object
we then accumulate that output so we
want to make sure that that latency
metric gets sent to the output of this
process for the second one it's a little
bit more complicated but this is a
dynamic counter mapping basically the
difference between the two is that in
the first one we have a very static name
for the metric whereas in the second one
we actually want to extract a value out
of out of a field and turn that into the
name of a metric in this case we want to
take the status code and put it into the
middle of the HTTP dot status count
string so that way a status code of 200
is going to become HTTP status 200 count
and 403 is going to be tough for a three
dot count this basically makes it very
easy to do sort of dynamic creation of
metrics where part of the metric name is
actually embedded in the data itself and
then we're going to set the value of
that to one because in this case we're
just counting every event that has that
that is code so talking a little bit
about the architecture of this thing
it's actually fairly simple those
configuration files they get parsed one
time when the system loads and they
actually get bound to these Java action
objects so basically every every
top-level line here is an action so
everything here becomes its own Java
object in the JVM then an important
thing is that this this library really
needs a driver program of some kind in
order to do things like initialize the
context that's how we actually get the
data loaded into initially as well as to
do something with the output so we've
got a driver program that we embed into
our system for any of the data that our
Kafka consumers are consuming so that
way any of the downstream systems where
we need to send the data that's flowing
through Kafka we can run it through this
engine before it gets to its destination
if you were embedding this into your own
program this would just be a small bit
of work for spark or flink or whatever
you're using in order to basically do
like you know instantiate the parser and
generate all of these objects and then
actually piping data through it's pretty
easy basically after you've initialized
the context there's just an an execute
action that happens at the very top and
the rest of it is handled for you so all
of the flow of control between those
actions is automatically built up by the
action tree that the parser is
generating and then the actions
themselves can read and write variables
in that global context and then when
you're done you can copy the output out
to the rest of your processing we do
support loading of custom actions we use
the Java services framework which is
basically some extra metadata that you
include in your jar file to tell
that this is an action that you want to
be able to use you drop the jar file
into your class path and then that's all
that's necessary for it to be registered
from our perspective any custom actions
appear as top-level actions there's
nothing special about the built-in
actions versus ones that you register
yourself in fact all of the built-in
actions are registered through the same
Java services framework that plugins use
there's basically two different methods
you need to implement there's an execute
method on the action itself that's
basically what the actions going to do
and then there's something called an
action builder which is actually what
binds to the configuration language and
ends up building your action objects and
there's a build method that you have to
implement for that so some examples of
custom actions that our customers have
used or created it can be for parsing
custom log formats something that's not
easy to do with a regular expression for
example so cisco acs Citrix juniper a
lot of our customers have custom log
formats that you've never seen before
and so they may need to work with us to
have custom actions for parsing that
kind of data we also use it a lot for
doing a lookup of data in the stream so
a common one is looking up IP addresses
in a G or IP database so you've got some
log data that's coming in that has IP
addresses maybe from your customers
hitting your website you want to have a
some semblance of idea of where those
IPS are coming from or where those
customers are coming from so you can do
that lookup right there in the
transformation engine or if you have any
other kind of reference data set so
maybe your logs maybe your logs contain
device IDs but you actually want to
translate that into a device name so
that when you're looking at events in
the UI you can actually understand what
you're looking at so just kind of
summarizing or bringing it back together
stream processing changes the way that
you think about data you no longer think
about
putting your data into a repository and
then processing it or querying it but
you think about how you want to look at
your data while it's in motion data
transformation is the first step for any
stream processing computation you always
need to do some form of filtering
extraction or projection in order for
your data to make sense it's otherwise
everyone that does any kind of
computation over the data is going to
have to repeat all of those steps over
again one of the reasons why we built
this library is that we want to be able
to experiment with different stream
processing frameworks so we can embed
this library and our direct Kafka
consumers we can embed it in spark
streaming we can bet it in flank and we
don't have to redo any of those sort of
preliminary data transformation steps we
can write one configuration and load it
in any of those different contexts and
this also reduces your reliance on
developers for doing those sort of first
phases of your stream processing
pipeline if you've got folks that want
to load their data into a stream and do
some lightweight ETL on it this is a
tool that's relatively more accessible
to them versus teaching them how to
write a spark job from scratch and then
the biggest one for us is that reusing
of the transformation logic we have many
different consumers that may be pulling
our data out of Kafka and we want to
make sure that any of those consumers
that need a particular transformation
applied have the option of applying that
transformation as they're reading the
data so right now this is proprietary
but we are going to be releasing it
under the Apache Software license soon
the configuration library that this is
based on which sort of is that JSON like
language is available today so if you're
interested in that that's up on github
and you can pull it down and play with
it with that there's plenty of time for
questions
hi
oh sure
any other questions yes yes
so we can do I described it as reference
data set lookups so we don't do we don't
do streaming joins so we don't join two
streams together that's not a use case
for our transformation engine we will do
a stream of records that's coming in and
we want to like look up in some
reference data set and so that's kind of
like a join but very simplified because
one of the tables that you're joining
against is very small and isn't a
national stream so yeah we don't do we
don't do joins in the in the
transformation library itself any kind
of joining of streams happens in the
higher-level stream processing framework
so the question was which stream
processing system do I think is the best
because I'm being recorded the answers
of course all of them in reality I don't
I don't actually know we play a lot with
spark streaming we're playing around
with flink
they all have benefits and drawbacks I
would recommend just looking at them
comparing them for your use cases
another great option is if you're not
sure what you want to adopt there's a
project called Apache beam which is a
general-purpose
API for stream processing frameworks
that came out of Google and it can work
with flank spark streaming I think storm
I could be wrong on that one
Google's dataflow engine I think that's
what it's called which is a part of
their Google cloud offering so that's an
API that you can use for doing stream
processing where you can change the
execution engine later so if you're not
really sure which one you want to rely
on building against a patchy beam may
give you some flexibility to migrate to
different frameworks down the road any
other questions
all right thank you very much